well Donald Trump has made his first
public appearance since that remarkable
indictment was unsealed and it was
trademark Trump this vicious persecution
is a travesty of Justice they want to
use something called the Espionage Act
doesn't that sound terrible oh Espionage
it was a grievance-laced speech he cast
himself as the victim of an
establishment out to get him the
narrative he's setting is that all this
is political not legal it's Biden trying
to stop him in the courts rather than
face him at The Ballot Box deflection to
the Clinton email Scandal and Biden's
own document Scandal play well there are
clear distinctions with those cases but
still the cries of double standards are
loud the core message is that the state
is out not just to get him but every one
of his supporters and it is effective
driving distrust into the institutions
which hold the country together if some
see this as a weak defense well the
rhetoric works with many Americans and
Trump knows it